safely returned to Ukraine completing a
9-year journey to Western Europe and
back the hundreds of artifacts some of
them thousands of years old had been on
loan to a museum in Amsterdam from
museums in Crimea when Russia invaded
and annexed the peninsula in
2014 when it was time to return them
keev went to court arguing it would be
effectively delivering to Russia an
important part of Ukrainian Heritage
it's a historical part of Ukraine it's a
it's a a part of integrated part of our
history actually crian history crian
culture impacted Ukraine's history a lot
the legal battle became a kind of proxy
fight over cultural identity with
Ukraine emphasizing its distinct
Heritage and also accusing Russia of
widespread abuse of its cultural
Treasures in the territories it's
occupied a year ago retreating Russian
forces in the southern Kon region
ransacked thousands of paintings and
artifacts from museums and churches
which keev says is a war crime for this
collection at least its safety seems
guaranteed and of course we will uh make
everything possible to to show abortion
in anyway of it and probably to make
some exhibition and to to tell about
Crimean history but Ukraine says the
collection will finally return to Crimea
when Crimea is returned to Ukraine Rob
McBride aljazera
Kei make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer